hello I'm wondering if I could trouble
you for a drink I should have a tab open
under the name annette bening craving
something with a little kick but do you
do these jalapeno margarita salt on the
rim little sprinkle of cayenne do you do
fresh limes bottled lime roses I'm cool
with anything but I just should know
because they're kind of pumping extra
sugar into those pot of lime juices
which you know is pretty gross you know
can you believe that actually the extra
sugar I mean what's this FDA doing now
that I'm thinking about that do you put
red chili flake in the margarita it's
dangerous
you can ask Billy Crudup the sweetest
dearest mouth you ever did meet he saw
me nearly choked to death at the 20th
century women rap party got launched my
uvula my throat right there hacking oh
we couldn't smoke just that deep that
gutter oh yeah they've been here this
isn't an airport I'm gonna baby I'm
sorry actually - oh my god
Oh Jeff remembered I have a voiceover
spot this week let's just cut all spice
altogether and while we're here I must
insist we use George's tequila I do not
know who that is George Clooney it's
your friend in the tequila it really is
the best and I wouldn't say that that
it's not who I am
actually he's the one who taught me the
difference between gold and silver
tequila and um they're gonna kill me
you're going to kill me you will murder
me because you know what after all
that's said in death what I really
wanted
yes hey that's a toy and a hot dog too
if you have it please it's really good
Channing Tatum